i'm tempted to play
uh the gerund back at you which is that
so github is currently is amazing but
the thing is if you have a stake then if
it's a social media platform they can
use the fact that you have a steak to
manipulate you because you want to
preserve the steak so like
right well this is why this all right
this gets us into the economics so
there's this thing called data dignity
that i've been studying for a long time
i wrote a book about an earlier version
of it called who owns the future um and
the the the basic idea of it is that
once again this is the third year
conversation the fascinating topic let
me do the fastest version of this i can
do the fastest way i know how to do this
is to compare two features all right uh
so
future one is then the normative one the
one we're building right now and future
two is going to be data dignity okay and
um and i'm gonna use a particular
population i live on the hill in
berkeley
and one of the features about the hill
is that as the climate changes we might
burn down and i'll lose our houses or
die or something like it's it's
dangerous you know and it didn't used to
be
and so
um who keeps us alive well the city does
the city does some things the electric
company kind of sort of maybe hopefully
better um individual people who own
property take care of their property
that's all nice but there's this other
middle layer which is fascinating to me
which is that the groundskeepers
who work up and down that hill many of
whom are not
legally here many of whom don't speak
english
cooperate with each other
to make sure trees don't touch to
transfer fire easily from la talat they
have this whole little web that's
keeping us safe i didn't know about this
at first i just started talking to them
because they were out there during the
pandemic and so i try to just see who
are these people who are these people
who are keeping us alive
now i want to talk about the two
different fates for those people under
future one and future two
future one um
some weird like kindergarten paint job
van with all these like cameras and
where things drives up observes what the
gardeners and groundskeepers are doing
a few years later some amazing robots
that can shimmy up trees and all this
show up all those people are out of work
and there are these robots doing the
thing and the robots are good and they
can scale to more land and they're
actually good but then they're all these
people out of work and these people have
lost dignity they don't know what
they're going to do
and and then somebody say well they go
on basic income whatever they become
wards of the state
my problem with that solution is every
time in history that you've had some
centralized thing that's stoling out the
benefits that things get seized by
people because it's too centralized and
it gets seized that's happened to every
communist experiment i can find
um so i think that turns into a poor
future that will be unstable i don't
think people will feel good in it i
think it'll be a political disaster with
the sequence of people seizing this
central source of the the basic income
and you'll say oh no an algorithm can do
it then people will seize the algorithm
they'll see they'll seize control unless
the algorithm is decentralized and it's
impossible to seize the control yeah but
but uh
60 something people own a quarter of all
the bitcoin like like the things that we
think are decentralized are not
decentralized
so let's go to future two future two
the gardeners see that that van with all
the cameras and the kindergarten paint
job and they say the groundskeepers and
they say hey the robots are coming we're
going to form a data union and amazingly
california has a little baby data union
law emerging in the books yes
and so there's and so they'll um and and
what they say they say we're going to
form
we're going to form a data union and
we're going to
not only are we going to sell our data
to this place but we're going to make it
better than it would have been if they
were just grabbing it without our
cooperation and we're going to improve
it we're going to make the robots more
effective we're going to make them
better and we're going to be proud of it
we're going to become a new class of
experts that are respected and then
here's the interesting there's two
things that are different about that
world
from future one one thing of course the
people have more pride they have more
sense
of of ownership of uh of of of agency
but
what the robots do changes uh instead of
just like this functional like we'll
figure out how to keep the neighborhood
from burning down uh
you have this whole creative community
that wasn't there before thinking well
how can we make these robots better so
we can keep on earning money there'll be
waves of
creative
uh groundskeeping with spiral pumping
pumpkin patches and waves of cultural
things there'll be new ideas like wow i
wonder if we could do something about
climate change mitigation with how we do
this what about what about fresh water
can we what about can we make the food
healthier what about what about all of a
sudden there'll be this whole creative
community on the case
and isn't it nicer to have a high-tech
feature with more creative classes than
one with more dependent classes isn't
that a better future but but but
future one and future two
have the same robots and the same
algorithms there's no technological
difference there's only a human
difference yeah
and that's second future too that's data
dignity
the economy that you're i mean the game
theory here is on the humans and then
the technology is just the tools that
enable yeah you know i mean i think you
can believe in ai and be in future too i
just think it's a little harder you have
to do you have to do more
um contortions it's possible so in the
case of social media
what does uh
data dignity look like is it people
getting paid for their data yeah i think
what should happen is in the future
there should be massive data unions
for people putting
content into the system and the state
unions smooth out the results a little
bit so it's not winner take all but at
the same time
and people have to pay for it too they
have to pay for
facebook the way they pay for netflix
with with an allowance for the poor
there has to be a there has to be a way
out too but the thing is people do pay
for netflix it's a going concern
people pay for xbox and playstation like
people there's enough people to pay for
stuff they want this could happen too
it's just that this precedent started
that moved in the wrong direction
and then what has to happen
uh the economy is a measuring device if
it's an
honest measuring device the outcomes for
people form a normal distribution a bell
curve and then so there should be a few
people who do really well a lot of
people who do okay and then we should
have an expanding economy reflecting
more and more creativity and expertise
flowing through the network and that
expanding economy moves the result just
a bit forward so more people are getting
money out of it than are putting money
into it so it gradually expands the
economy and lifts all boats and the in
the society has to support
the the lower wing of the bell curve too
but not universal basic income it has to
be
for the you know because if it's an
honest if it's an honest economy there
will be
uh that lower wing and we we have to
support those people there has to be a
safety net
but
see what i believe i'm not going to talk
about ai but i will say
that i think there'll be more and more
algorithms that are useful and so i
don't think everybody's going to be
supplying data to grounds keeping robots
nor do i think everybody's going to make
their living with tick-tock videos i
think in both cases they'll be a rather
small contingent
that do well enough at either of those
things but i think there might be many
many many many of those niches that
start to evolve is there more and more
algorithms more and more robots and it's
that large number
that will create the economic potential
for a very large part of society to
become members of new creative classes
you